pues estás muy buenas tardes
efectivamente la situación el pervertido
muy dramática se calcula más de 200.000
fallecimientos a causa del coito y el
primer estimado fue la revista the
lancet que habló hace unos meses de 93
niños niñas o adolescentes en situación
de orfandad desde el estado peruano se
ha buscado abordar esta problemática y
en el mes de abril se inició una
asistencia económica pero que primero
cubría 300 beneficiarios ya con este
gobierno hemos ido incrementando y hemos
podido llegar a más de 19 mil en estos
momentos niños niñas y adolescentes que
reciben una asistencia económica
equivale a 50 dólares mensuales y lo que
estamos desarrollando es un modelo de
acompañamiento para que el estado pueda
garantizar de que sigan con sus estudios
que tengan servicios de salud que se
vinculen a otros programas sociales que
tengan asistencia psicológica también ya
mencionábamos esta ayuda del ministerio
de 200 soles cómo se entrega a quién se
le entrega es en dinero o es o se hace
algún tipo de estudio para que necesita
cada menor
en estos momentos tiene que haber alguno
de los familiares puede ser un padre la
madre o un cuidador que haga el papel de
administrador que hace la solicitud al
ministerio presenta la documentación
correspondiente y luego una evaluación
se pasa a hacer esta entrega que se hace
a través de un banco de los 200 soles
mensuales hacemos un seguimiento de que
el monto se esté utilizando y que sea
utilizado en beneficio de los niños y
niñas pero naturalmente necesitamos
mucho más apoyo por eso es que hemos
presentado un proyecto de ley al
congreso de la república para poder
ampliar este beneficio esperemos que
pueda llegar en algún momento a 85 mil
niños niñas y adolescentes y que
funcione este modelo de acompañamiento
que te venía comentando usted nos
mencionaba que ya se ven beneficiados
unas 10 y 19 mil familias cómo se va a
lograr ampliar este beneficio hasta
llegar a los afectados a todos
bueno lo principal es el proyecto de ley
que hemos presentado este primer
beneficio económico surgió a partir de
un decreto de urgencia del gobierno de
transición pero es importante que esto
ya quede como una política de estado
como un programa permanente por eso
estamos a la espera de la aprobación en
el congreso ya al ministerio economía y
finanzas nos ha dado el visto bueno para
poder tener ese presupuesto y lo que
queremos hacer además es que no
solamente sea por kobe sino por
diferentes causales en el perú tenemos
muchos fallecimientos lamentablemente
por accidentes de tránsito por otras
enfermedades también como el cáncer y es
importante que todos estén cubiertos que
toda la niñez pueda tener protección del
estado